Have you ever
heard the phrases,
"The results were
significant early.
I guess I can call it now,"
or "My boss is getting really
antsy.
I think she wants the
test results soon.
They seem directionally
positive,"
or "We really need to
balance statistical rigor
with the needs of the business."
The same flurry of phrases
would always overwhelm the data
scientists in my meetings.
Bad fluorescent
overhead lighting,
illuminating the battleground
between statistical rigor
and the omnipresent
needs of the business.
As a former data
scientist turned
product manager and
self-declared data nerd,
I see both sides of the story.
I wanted to help bridge the gap
between my business and data
peers by understanding
experimental methods that
allow organization to
run tests more quickly
and maintain statistical rigor.
Today, I'll walk you through
three easy-to-follow steps,
motivated by my own
experiences at Intuit.
So that you can apply
it to your own use cases
for running experiments
more quickly
and statistically rigorously.
First, we'll talk about how
to take big swings so you
can learn and fail quickly.
Two, we'll talk about
what sequential testing is
and how to use it, so that you
can end test early confidently.
And three, we'll talk about how
to use R so that I and you can
share your learnings
with your organization
even non-data scientists.
In reality, businesses
do need to move quickly
to stay innovative.
However, the results
of reading a test early
could be catastrophic, leading
to your business decision
being no better
than a coin flip.
Here is data for
simulated A/A test, a test
where we have two
cohorts but they have
exactly the same experience.
We know that since these
two experiences are exactly
the same, there should be
no statistically significant
difference between the two.
However, as you can see,
over a 30-day window,
the P value actually crosses
the significance threshold
a number of times all
due to random chance.
If you were to call
your test early,
you could be reading
the same noise.
And instead of making an
informed data-backed business
decision, you could simply
be rendering your business
decision no better than
if you had flipped a coin.
The first big
experiment I ever ran,
I fell prey to
this exact fallacy.
We were testing a new version
of a recommendation model.
And we wanted to test our
recommendation model out
in the wild.
It's an older iteration.
This was the perfect
candidate for an A/B test.
However, to move our
baseline metric of 3%,
we needed almost
a million samples.
And it would take us
three months to run.
Guess what?
No surprise, we cheated.
For the recommendation
experiment,
we used three-day connection
rate as a baseline metric.
This suffered from being a
bottom of the funnel metric
because not only did the users
have to see the recommendation
and click on it, then
they had to connect
and also hold on
to that connection
for at least three days for
us to register that as a win.
That led to our metric
being only 2.88%,
which is fairly low.
To make matters worse we were
taking only a tiny swing,
only aiming to move our
baseline metric by 3%.
With such a low minimum
detectable effect 3%,
we needed 12 weeks
or three months
to be able to fully
bake our test.
If you think about
it, we were looking
to move a baseline metric
of 2.88% by only 3%,
which led to an
absolute-- would have
led to an absolute lift of less
than a tenth of a percent.
If we had taken a bigger
swing of 10%, 7.5%,
or even just 5% as our
minimum detectable effect,
we could have
reduced our test time
from 12 weeks we needed
to just two weeks.
A year later, we ran
a second experiment,
where we wanted to
learn from our missteps
from our first experiment.
In the second
experiment, we wanted
to test automating sales tax.
We wanted to show users
country-specific sales tax
rate for their
region and their
first time use experience.
And this time, we wanted to
apply the principle of taking
big swings to our test.
This time, we used a metric
much closer to the user
action, engagement clicks,
with a relatively high baseline
of about 7%.
More importantly,
we declared that we
were going to take
a big swing and set
our minimum detectable
effect had to be 100%.
Meaning, that our baseline
conversion rate, 7%,
had to double to 14%.
This time, we were able
to take our projected
timeline to be only two weeks.
The key idea, taking big swings
to learn and fail quickly
is one of the biggest
levers you can push
to speed up your experiments.
But we wanted to do even better.
By taking our experimental
philosophy of taking big swings,
we were able to layer on an A/B
testing enhancement, sequential
testing, which allowed us to
take our two-week test time
and actually cut it in
half to just one week.
But what is sequential testing?
Sequential testing is kind
of like doing your taxes.
It allows you to not
overspend and waste time
waiting for results when you
could have already called it.
But it also ensures
that you don't
underspend time and
actually call a test that's
not statistically rigorous.
Sequential testing
allows you to take
that-- spend that exact
right amount of time,
such that when
you call the test,
you didn't overspend
or underspend time
to be able to call a winner.
The way that it does
that is by building
in a checkpoint or
multiple checkpoints,
where you can check the
results of your test and peek
earlier than a standard
fixed horizon test.
Sequential testing is also
ideal for software situations
because software gives
us the unique ability
to monitor results
in real time, which
means that any
moment of a peek, we
can go ahead and analyze
the results in that moment.
Additionally, since we have
their experimental philosophy
of taking big swings,
it really lends
itself to sequential testing
because sequential testing has
unique ability to
call winners early.
For a sales tax test, we
applied to checkpoints-- one
at the 50% mark or half of the total
samples had come in and one
at the 100% mark where our
full sample set to come
in at approximately two weeks.
At each checkpoint,
you can see that we
have a z-score
acceptance criteria
necessary to be able to
successfully determine
a winner.
The acceptance criteria are much
more stringent in the earlier
checkpoints to account for
the smaller sample size
that you're using to determine
whether there's a winner.
Note that the z-score
acceptance criteria
is greater than the 1.96
critical value, which
we normally see during
fixed horizon testing.
It's there because we're
paying a small price
to be able to peek earlier.
Namely, the price is
that our experiment
is slightly less powerful
in a statistical sense,
so that we may miss the
detection of a true effect
or win.
In this case, we're
using something called
the O'Brien-Fleming boundary,
which we've chosen because it
tries to minimize that
payment at the end of the test
because we're trying to get
as close to the 1.96 critical
value as we can
with that last peek.
As an aside, if you
want to check out more,
there's many more
boundaries you can use,
which may suit your needs more.
I wanted to make building
a sequential test
plan as simple as
possible to abstract
away the statistical
complexities
so that anyone at my
company could use it.
To do that, I designed
and built an R
flexdashboard to make creating
a test plan as simple as filling
out just a few data points.
Here, you can see
my flexdashboard,
my sales tax test prefilled.
We included the
baseline conversion rate
of our primary metric at
7.03, the power we wanted
or 80% here, which
is an industry
standard, statistical
significance level of 5%,
which is also an
industry standard.
And here, we included our big
swing recruitment of 100%.
And finally, we included
the optional value
of a weekly traffic to help
translate our sample size
requirement to the amount
of time we would need.
Until this point,
these are all values
you would include in a normal
A/B test plan sample size
calculation.
The only additional value
we needed to include
was the number of peeks we
wanted to take during our test.
Since our normal
A/B test already
had an estimated
time of two weeks,
we only wanted to
add one checkpoint
to be able to account for
normal weekly behavioral
fluctuations.
Therefore, here, we include the
number of peeks to be just 2.
At the top, we have three
key numbers available--
the number of peeks or 2 in
this case that we've set,
the total number of
samples that we would need,
and finally the total
amount of time it would take
given the number of samples
and our average weekly traffic.
Both of these numbers are based
on a normal A/B testing sample
calculation-- sample
size calculation.
Here, our table shows us the
breakdown of samples needed--
number of days and then
the lower and upper z-score
thresholds for each
checkpoint given
all of our inputted values.
Finally, our threshold
graph also [INAUDIBLE]
z-score threshold changes
with each checkpoint.
Ultimately, being able
to use this dashboard
and share out my
test plan, I was
able to go from an earlier
test with one million samples
to only needing 294
samples and taking
half the time of a normal
fixed tries in A/B test.
And instead of taking
three months to bake,
we only need to wait one week.
And instead of needing
the full bake time,
we were able to have multiple
checkpoints to really get
the right amount of time
to be able to guarantee
statistical rigor
without wasting any time.
And finally, the most
important of all,
remove the temptation
to cut corners.
And instead, we're
able to guarantee
statistically rigorous results
at shorter time points.
So how do we get there?
As a reminder, there
are three simple steps
you need take to
be able to achieve
these goals for yourself.
One, remember to
take big swings.
Don't take a minimum detectable
effect that's too small.
That's a huge lever to be able
to make your experiment shorter
right off the bat.
Two, use sequential testing.
Now, that you know
how, it can be
simple to just implement and
overlay on top of your own A/B
tests.
And three, using our Shiny
flexdashboard or your own tool
of choice to be
able to demonstrate
how to do this to everyone
in your organization
and share the goodness that
is sequential testing, so
that everyone, even
non-data scientists,
can run shorter, more
statistically rigorous tests.
Now, with just those three tips
and tricks in your tool belt,
you can avoid early
significant results,
disappointing your antsy boss,
and business constraints.
Because now, you
have all the tools
you need to be able to run your
tests shorter and reliably,
so that everyone in the
organization can feel confident
in your results.